hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to bad dream coma now
we're going into an apartment and I
don't know what apartment we're going oh
I don't know what apartment we're going
into but we'll find out very soon
this looks lovely what a great place
we've got here Oh delightful hello how
are you doing
yes I'll come right in thank you I
didn't do that okay crowbar na koi no no
love fire know what's going on here
hello electrical service and four
premises number one has been turned off
the service will be restored after
paying the overdue bill kind of world
that we live in is someone's greatest
fear in this coma not paying their bills
big dong dong dong can I take that hello
hello hello anybody there
no all right that's it so I gotta go
forward so let's try to O letter O what
if I what if I drop this mail okay so I
got to do something with this
electricity bill before this will be
restored
oh oh oh darkness my friend okay I don't
like that I can barely see but I can see
a little bit which worries me oh good Oh
bright why is that so dark in there
I urgently need money to continue the
treatment
I hope the Tooth Fairy will help me
again if I don't get money quickly then
there's nothing left but believing in
magic well you're kinda in a coma world
but have you been pulling out your teeth
I'm placing it under your pillow that
seems not fun
why the hell just happened
oh hi what a lovely family
you have there oh I got a button bye why
what the [ __ ] is happening whoa boy aah
dark great still dark hello wait is any
of this we don't remember that house
[Music]
Buzzle pieces are puzzling together the
key fell into the toilet again right can
you get it
No who are you talking to me Oh found a
pen
okay can I okay I got to be able to
write on this right it's got to be a
world where I can set the paper down
right on it and then put it in the
mailbox or get some money to put with it
maybe they got some money here that I
can stir so there's got to be some money
somewhere cuz I got a pen zoom
apparently oh the piggy bank can I smash
open the pogey barn
a fake going in there what Oh put that
in there sign it no put a fake coin in
there put a button in there
no okay that's almost there I get it
Skoosh alright anything else over here
there's got to be something to do with
those piggy banks right it's got to be
something to do with that oh I put a
fake point in there maybe that means it
put a real coin cuz the five was
backwards Oh break open you I got a coin
I got a coin Lamont all right on this
electricity bill okay that's weird but
whatever what else do I need a ride all
I need a stamp I gotta find a stamp
don't I I don't know where I'm gonna
find a storm we're gonna where am I
gonna find a stoop I don't have a stoop
oh the pain dependent we owe my god the
pen made more what the hell is with that
what is with that that's so weird
I've literally made this place
[Music]
I don't like that who's providing all of
this go oh all right then
that was fun I'm glad that hey where
there's got to be something down here
right got to be something else down here
yeah but I don't have I don't have
anything with which to do about this yet
so maybe not yet but that did add
something so maybe that changed
something else cuz sometimes you have to
view something before you can actually
like dude hey birdie
how you doing bird bird would you like a
button I gave a button a bird the last
time oh hello I got a Foos ok so maybe
if I put the Foos in on the other side
who's that do some been gonna make you
all better
what does that do what that do what did
that do that did something ahh lights Oh
in here yes please yes give me the key
in the turlet hello hidey hidey hidey ho
is there a key in the toilet okay so
it's not here yet did something but not
enough
making progress but very piecemeal very
slowly very student so eventually
eventually I'll have to get that fuse
back up now I don't know why they got
their bathrooms under power lock but you
know Oh what the hell was that what oh
my god I've been looking for that stamp
for everywhere oh well now it's iodine
rod it's the tiniest details are too
fine anyway there we go bloom got that
all done alright good now what I gotta
get the power back on but it's back on
anyway there's a what is that a plunger
well I can use the plunger on the other
toilet which I guess is good so let me
go over to the other world because
apparently I was solving this puzzle
before I even got to the point where I
needed to solve the puzzle because for
some reason there's a lot of keys in
toilets never mind
oh maybe it's in the basement wait maybe
it flushed down to the basement because
there was a bunch of Skoosh juice coming
- yes that's a hammer that's key but I
don't know why there's a hammer there
there wasn't a hammer before there was
there maybe the key to the other place
come on Oh Cosette
well there was a radio in the mirror
world in this room you say hello I'm
home I don't like that help help you
I'll take this paperclip thank you I
don't know who you want help from I
can't even help myself at this point
who's going for it
huh who's calling for help oh whoa hello
living room who was in here why do I did
I pick up a hot dog where's that the
first thing I did six three seven five
one one can't dial that but six three
seven five one one oh I got a die for my
board game great six to seven five one
one six three seven five one one okay
goody I got a hot dog I got a sausage
pacifically I got a sausage six three
seven five one one oh hello okay sure ah
why does that look like I want to be the
guy goddamn and why does that look like
trogdor that's weird all right how about
dice I'll roll it
yeah all right do that don't do that to
me come on oh oh okay good all right you
sack of [ __ ] if you would have done that
I would have been I would have been very
upset okay I would have been varying me
upset and burn it and burn it all down
whoa four okay
three okay or alrighty then 1204 right
six spooky doing good so far I don't
know if there's any way not to do good
Oh for or leave
well I guess I just gotta keep playing
this huh yeah just barely not come on ah
you [ __ ] me no I you [ __ ] me ah come
on come on luck me don't let mom luck me
like that
don't luck me like that Oh give it to me
oh I don't that's such [ __ ] okay
well this is gonna be while I'll be back
when this works there we go eat NYX man
that took a while there was some Hey
look I played your game I did it I'm
such a cool pers hi who are you
well you why you got a teddy bear on you
sure do you have a teddy bear do you
have an imaginary friend there's a teddy
bear where did you get my game I've
wanted to get rid of it because it
seemed dumb to me we can't afford a
computer so for now I need to make board
games there's little we can afford my
parents treatment costs a great deal of
money as long as you've already played
it tell me if you really like it
I'd like to design games one day anyway
what are you doing here my parents sent
you here I don't know where they are
I'm afraid the death may have got him
I'm worried about them so much maybe
they went to our old house the one near
the forest could you look for them there
I'm too little to go there alone anyway
I have to watch the house you don't need
to worry about me very brave and smart
just like me just go I'm worried about
my parents okay okay all right then
well that's the end of that chapter oh
man so that kid must be like the source
of all this right or the reason that
death was stopped and maybe he created a
game I have no idea it's it's it's
confusing but we're getting to the
bottom of it so thank you everybody so
much for watching let me know what you
think down the comments below
as always I will see you in the next
video
[Music]